[Music]
when you have a data intensive
application such as health insurance and
your on-premise traditional data
warehouse does not quite fit the pace
and the wallet with which your data
science team wants to innovate you know
it's time to migrate your data warehouse
to cloud so today i invited gary moriali
director of data services team to share
with us how they migrated their data
warehouse to bigquery to innovate faster
hi gary welcome to the show hi thanks
for having me well let's start with what
is your role sure what my team does
the data services team is we support all
the databases at the organization so i
imagine it is large amount of data as a
data team what's your team's biggest
challenge so our biggest challenge is
getting that data into our databases and
then getting it back out in a timely
fashion so we can meet the businesses
needs so how much amount of data are we
talking about here we're talking about
terabytes of data and it's continuously
growing as everybody in the industry
probably knows
it's got an exponential curve to it and
it's getting bigger all the time so it
sounds like the biggest goal was to
really create a forward-looking system
to store this ever-growing data in a
secure scalable and also cost-effective
manner so getting that data in and out
and making that data available to all of
our users we have thousands of users and
terabytes of data and meeting those
challenges was getting harder and harder
in our existing environment all right so
migration from on-premise data warehouse
to bigquery is quite an undertaking
definitely not flip of the switch kind
of migration you need to make sure your
downstream systems uh in this case
thousands of downstream systems don't
break due to inconsistent results in
your final tables after your migration
so how did you approach this migration
so we engaged data medica one of
google's business partners to help us
complete an assessment of everything we
have today which included not just our
data warehouse but all the applications
that use it and all the processes that
pull data in and take data out and they
were able to come back and give us a
complete picture of what it was we were
going to be dealing with
well after hearing that solid migration
plan i'm very excited to dive into the
migration architecture sounds like this
is an ongoing migration right now walk
me through so the first thing we had to
do was put the foundation in place so
that involved getting our networking set
up getting the environment in google set
up all the connections between the
different you know environments here and
and there between our data center and
google so we got all that in place
and then once that was there then we
were able to start working on moving the
data over so we have all the data in our
existing system and we used a transfer
agent to transfer to big query
moves and that allowed us to pull the
data into cloud storage and then from
there
the data went into
data quality checks via data flow which
allowed us to move the data into the
environment we were able to set that
scheduling up using cloud composer uh to
do scheduling and orchestration as well
then we got it into the staging
environment in bigquery which allowed us
to push it into our core environment and
then our information layer so that our
end users would have access to
everything
and then we have to worry about keeping
everything in sync right because while
we're in the migration process which
will go on for some time we need to make
sure that what was happening in the old
system is what's happening in the new
system and pelican is the tool with a
gta g key e cluster that uh
allows us to do that comparison between
the two and make sure things stay in
sync which has been a really good
feature gives us a lot of confidence in
what we're doing
and then the end result of all this is
that our consumers on
you know the final end of this journey
people using sql server reporting
services tableau other applications
we've written or third-party
applications
are able to now just point at bigquery
instead of pointing at our existing
system and do the same things that they
were doing previously
well awesome that was a lot now
given your consumers of the data which
is the data scientists and the business
analytics team
you have this modern data warehouse in
bigquery at this point how do you ingest
and process the data and then how do
data science and business analytics team
um do their job which is analyze this
data and make predictions
sure
well we have a lot of different data
sources being a health insurer we get
data from various providers like
hospitals and doctors offices
testing centers things like that we also
get data from our members and then we
have a lot of processing business
partners that we work with as well as
government entities so we needed a way
to set up secure file transfers which we
can do and we can load that into cloud
storage and then uh use api based
services as well to do the same thing
and then we can move that using data
proc
with our hadoop type environments that
we're used to using
to load the data up into bigquery so now
we've got everything in place and the
data scientists can then use the tools
that they're used to using which in this
case would be the vertex artificial
intelligence pipelines that are provided
in the google environment they use
jupiter notebooks to work with all of
that
they're able to take advantage of the
fact that it's not a static environment
like we had before so they can add
resources for example gpus become a huge
benefit in this environment to data
scientists so they can dynamically add
them as needed
and then what they end up doing in the
end is they build models that help us
you know assess and do preventative care
understand what's going on with our
pharmacies what risks people may have
what kind of fraud might be going on
it just allows them to do the magic that
it is the data scientists do and
understanding how all this data can be
put to use to make our members health
better that is amazing so what is next
in this architecture and what's your
team working on now so the nice thing is
now that we have this foundation in
place the security the networking all of
that we can start to look at what other
types of
opportunities there might be so we've
been looking at uh voice recognition
software we've been looking at different
types of reporting tools that are
provided up there
there's just a whole host
of different applications that are
provided on the google platform that we
can now
easily put into place compared to before
having to buy
you know different hardware in our own
data center so it just
presents a lot of opportunities and
we're looking at a lot of them well now
that everything is in one place and your
infrastructure layers are all set up you
can
just innovate on top of that which is
amazing thank you so much gary and we
congratulate you for what you have
accomplished you and the team have
accomplished and we look forward to
seeing more updates on this architecture
great thank you it's been great talking
to you today if you have any specific
topics or industry architectures you
would like me to cover put them in the
comments and i will bring them to you
you